si on veut mettre à terre le pont si on
veut le détruire 300 millions de dollars
et laon il transmet les voitures par
jour il ya le train youtube qui passent
sur le pont
donc si ce n'est pas un enjeu c'est
incontournable qu'on doit maintenir le
pont en place il souhaite que dans le
cadre du 100e anniversaire du pont soit
le 20 septembre 2010 est qu une solution
soit enfin trouvée pour sécuriser le
pont et enlever toute la rouille à la
fin du mois d'août où on à mobiliser la
société civile chambre de commerce de
lévis et chants de commerce de québec et
aussi la faculté des sciences et génie
de l'université laval pour préparer un
forum pour aller chercher les meilleures
pratiques et des pistes de solution il
faut trouver des façons de valoriser
puis ça passe de façon inconditionnelle
par la restauration et par l'entretien
du pont dont la peinture
donc faut sortir du des de ce qu'on
connaît actuellement des enjeux qui sont
devant sa balle un geyser à l'autre pour
arriver avec un vrai modèle de
gouvernance pour en assurer la pérennité
la pérennité pardon et la mise en valeur
et c'est là qu'on doit arriver que
modèles d'affaires innovants qui
touchent évidemment l'entretien la
restauration la peinture mais aussi la
valorisation du pont c'est un pont du
patrimoine canadien c'est le seul pont
du patrimoine canadien et pour pour
aller à l'unesco par exemple il faut il
faut le valoriser en ce moment 100
millions de dollars de fonds publics
sont sur la table pour repeindre le pont
alors que les travaux coûteront 4 fois
plus cher
le gouvernement canadien ne veut pas
d'une facture de 400 millions
l'engagement que nous avions tenu de
fournir à 75 millions
alors là lors la campagne c'est toujours
sauf que quand le soir avec une vision
que nous continuons à mettre 2 les reins
et le 350 à 400 millions qui est
maintenant de d'accord commun il ya une
grosse marche lundi ministre responsable
du grand nord canadien jean yves duclos
maintient que la balle est maintenant
dans le camp des maires de québec et
lévis qui doivent décider s'ils
repeindre le pont et le réparer demeure
une priorité que nous continuons à tenir
notre promesse d'être disposés et
disponible peau
pourquoi aller de l'avant avec son
éclosion qui est toujours là ceci étant
dit nous soulignons aussi que dans dans
la région québec pour fait déjà beaucoup
d'investissements cours des prochaines
années
savez que vous êtes rude où le
gouvernement fait clairement part de sa
volonté d'être présents dans la région
québec ont déjà commencé à faire pas mal
de choses y en a d'autres qui s'en
viennent plus nous allons ateliers les
faire toujours en collaboration avec le
québec la ville de québec et la ville de
lille
on offre 75 millions et après c'est aux
gens de québec de trouver une solution
vous avez besoin d'un match s'est engagé
à investir des miens et facétieux pour
les dix prochaines années
c'est pas vrai qu'on n'est pas capable
de trouver un candidat sur dix ans qui
fait en sorte que des investissements
partagés après impôts ce soit pour les
annales
la région s'est fait rouler dans faire
de m les élections sont terminées se
terminer plus d'engagement on s'est
trompé
on n'est pas dur c'est nous prendre pour
des enfants d'école on n'est pas des
enfants naturels et c'est pas une façon
de commencer à travailler avec des
partenaires
c'est sûr que c'est une promesse qui est
rompu si c'est vraiment de façon
cavalière de faire les choses on ne peut
pas traiter le mans comme son de porter
la population comme ça si la sueur
semble perdue au fond des mers de la
ville de québec de lévis et des élus de
toute cette région c'est que le temps
pour réparer des fissures et enlever la
rouille et d'os repeindre commence à
faire défaut le pont de québec a été
désigné déjà en 2015 comme étant l'un
des dix sites les plus menacés au canada
une liste dressée par héritage canada la
fiducie nationale un organisme de
bienfaisance qui mentionne que la
corrosion accélérée par l'exposition à
des conditions météorologiques extrêmes
finira par compromettre les propriétés
mécaniques du pont voir son intégrité
structurelle j'irai xi dans les cinq ou
dix années ont offert hier de passage
dans la ville de québec cette semaine
l'homme d'affaires belge bruno saberi a
travaillé pendant 30 ans comme assurant
de produits anti corrosion
il est maintenant propriétaire d'une
entreprise contre la rouille et qui a
déjà traité des ponts se trouvant en
norvège aux états unis en australie et
en chine
problème de stabilité et peut-être de
pièces qui vont qui vont se détache y
est qui qui mettront pour véritablement
en danger non seulement le pont mais les
gens qui traversent
j'en ai vu comme ça au myanmar au laos
cambodge tout dans les pays je dirais
autour de l'équateur la veine humilité
très importante
l'historien du pont de québec michel
l'hébreux qui réclament un meilleur
entretien du paon depuis 28 ans se
réjouit de cette nouvelle voie qui
s'ajoute à la sienne comme je vous dis
ça fait des années que je me bats ça
fait 28 ans qu'on a fondé le comité j'ai
écrit des livres j'ai donné plus de 2000
conférence pour vanter les mérites du
pont québec c'est pas un monument comme
un autre le pont québec c'est un
monument exceptionnel alors raison plus
de lui donner fière allure
le temps est précieux le pont de québec
est centenaire mais sa vie durable est
compté le pont de québec est déjà dans
les livres des records pour s'être
effondré non pas une fois mais deux fois
c'était lors de sa construction en 1907
et une seconde fois en 1916 alors qu'on
est en train d'ajouter les derniers
boulons donc tout à la liait jusqu'à
l'érection de nos mains si code est
professeur au département de génie civil
de l'école polytechnique de l'université
de montréal donc d'intégrer le va bien
et elle n'était pas aussi probablement
pour effet connaître une question comme
beaucoup de fois et le degré gérer sur
le déçu le système poussait sur des
pièces étaient en dessous de la table et
on pousse vers le haut et a déstabilisé
la partie avale un reportage de radio
canada international